oh it's white we're so close just buy us
a few more minutes
well they just called me in for an
update so i'll call you right back
okay okay great
hey dwight uh send in the subs
oh
you left then a month later you took
terry with you
yeah well we needed a mindless fact
totem and he's the best there is
amen then you took april
i didn't want her to go as she had
become one of my closest
workplace acquaintances but your offer
was too good to pass up so i didn't try
to stop her
and tom left to run his business donna
left to run hers
one day i looked up and just didn't
recognize anyone
so i made a decision an
unthinkable decision
hey well my my my do my eyes deceive me
is that ron swanson
hello leslie hello april larry
uh it's terry now okay as luck would
have it oh
did you talk to randy about the vote
tell the northeast that we need to put
pressure on them or else we're gonna be
waiting for everyone i'm tired of
waiting on them okay sorry this is a
crazy day
so what's up with you you big lug
nothing important just thought you might
want to have lunch
uh tomorrow i would love to it's been
too long
jj's diner 12 30. excellent see you then
okay
so randy says the house is voting
tomorrow and they need us in washington
to prep oh my god really
okay get us the first flight out of here
and grab the missouri files meet me at
my car
hey babe i got to go to washington can
you pick up the kids
oh oh no ron i stood you up for lunch
you did yes i waited for a while but it
was pretty easy to figure out what had
happened
your life seemed pretty hectic is that
the rest of the story that i stood you
up
you were going to ask me something
that's why you wanted to have lunch
ron you were going i was gonna ask you
for a job
in the federal government just saying it
out loud feels dirty
if i could have your attention please
i'm being transferred to the public
relations office i'm leaving the
nine-nine effective immediately
what the hell i don't understand what
the hell why are you doing this
what the hell i want to say it has been
a pleasure to have worked alongside all
of you for the past 21 and a half months
i'm sorry for getting so emotional
pretty consistent tone actually these
have been the
these have been the best years of my
career
oh no this is new and i know that
every one of you give me everything you
had
and i will never forget it go back to
being robot captain
me more see
dismissed
sir i'm coming with you
thank you gina i'm also coming not
necessary
so i've been meaning to tell you i want
to take you out for lunch for your last
day
oh what do you think tomorrow lunch you
and me
okay
you're not leaving tomorrow you're
leaving today right
maybe wow so that's it huh just
four o'clock and you were gone for good
why am i so sad
am i doing the wrong thing absolutely
not
it's just that sometimes goodbyes are a
[ __ ]
t-shirt idea goodbye stink
okay all right so
james halpert
you started with his company
as a fine young man you know what i
think we should do i think we should
just say the goodbyes for tomorrow
at lunch oh
okay and then tomorrow
i can tell you what a great
boss you turned out to be
best boss i ever had
oh shoot that's my cab
all right all right listen michael i i
really
i did text pam but i know it's okay
just give her a hug all right
i will see you tomorrow at lunch i am
looking forward to lunch
and hearing about what a great buzz like
you got it
okay yeah
i guess this is it hey will you guys let
me know if this ever airs
thank you all right oh
this is gonna feel so good
getting this thing off my chest
so
no he wasn't sad he was full of hope
about colorado and he was hoping to get
an upgrade as an awards member
and he said he was just really excited
to get home and see holly
the recount's over they just called the
race oh god
it's still 21 votes
but you won
you won leslie you won by 21 votes
it's confirmed it's over you won
that was really sneaky and i know i
couldn't resist
uh for a woman uh a lady
uh women two women they're holding hands
uh friends um uh
sisters oh business partners oh um
oh oh oh co-owners of a chocolate shop
oh
love love what do women love george
clooney
it's a wedding they're brides they're in
love
mom dad i know you don't want to talk
about this but
i do i might get married to a man like
you so clearly want
and i might not because this is not a
phase and i need you to understand that
i'm bisexual there's no such thing as
being bisexual yes there is
i know there is because that's who i am
i'm attracted to both men and women
i've known this about myself for a
really long time and i didn't want to
tell you because i was afraid you were
going to react exactly like you are
what do you want to say
that you accept me for who i am
wow
okay let's go hey what's everybody doing
tonight
nothing why there's something we all
need to do
what's going on family game night don't
worry i brought twister
hey hey what's that hey frozen there was
a snacks
you know in another lifetime you and i
would have made a hot-ass couple
agreed
[Music]
yes you should be very proud of yourself
i know things aren't exactly where you
want to be right now
but uh i promise you they will improve
thank you captain
every time someone steps up and says who
they are the world becomes a
better more interesting place so
thank you
hey do you seriously only have two wine
glasses yeah i live alone well you're
gonna need to get some more cause
there's a lot of us here
thank you for doing this man of course
we'll be here every week
rosa i broke both your wine glasses in
your fridge door in your bathroom
every single week
you